under the keyboard that's inappropriate
are you trying to hit on me right now
that was gone
[Music]
oh god I hate vodka
[Music]
I have never been to escape the room I
don't even know what what it is I
honestly I think it's like a trivia it's
like an intense puzzle basically much I
guess like a roller coaster for your
mind I think the game is based on
hopefully our logic
like alcohol will be a benefit I'm like
so buzzed it like champagne gives me two
fillings like either just graduated
college or I need to nap for like a good
six hours I'm nervous I believe in us
let's do it we got this I literally have
no idea what to expect
[Music]
you guys must find a master class career
is on the line you'll be kicked back
school guys later start yeah Terry stop
guys Gary yeah so you guys are still
looking still looking for the first clue
[Music]
what a minute sorry I feel like we've
gotten so much further than
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're doing this very fast and I'm very
impressed
I feel like all the other things the
alcohol helps with this party making it
really difficult for number six it's
gotta be another way
oh wait you guys just going jump and do
it I'm not as old as you Rendon jumping
doesn't do anything for me I mean it
could be just like France but I don't
think France is a gift I don't want to
do I want to do it really hot the best
is over do we stop you know I'm sorry oh
yeah that was creepy as hell thank you
[Music]
oh wait how do they get out remove the
letters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was stopped by what anybody's saying
it was just like a group effort into it
and like you know I think the record
time we made out you guys this was a
great team I felt supported felt like we
like complemented each other's thought
process like found clues before they
were relevant yeah me too
that's alright guys still made it out
under 60 minutes it's all it matters
that's true and we made it out if you
wish we'd met we beat the silver team
because that would have been I feel like
the planks as well yes I played out in a
different part yeah I mean pretty good
for the amount that we ran it in there's
so many more reasons with Justin
[Music]